今日は傘で紹介する商品はコチラな
森永さんからの
江戸米菓クレイ三島てる ga ずのビュー0
なんとこちら今だけのスペシャルねーくというほどて言っております
あ私かかった地震でもですね大変更チーズ家はとても好きでございましてね
チーズ間には目がないのでございますはいこちらの商品
準チョコレート製品ということで
まあ
ハイブリッドはか何をわかんないんですけどね
ご覧くださいこそが従来のニュービーズを比べてこんなに薄い方に行っております
コンパクトな仕上がりで大変使い勝手が良いようでございます
では早速中身の方を開けていきたいとおもいます
んですかねあっ
ああなんということでしょう
頭痛
ずっ粒入っております
ああああああ
このようにデザインまでも大変チーズっぽい音になっておりますチーズ好きの方お
見逃しなくをご購入ください
こちらご覧ください従来の商品と大きさは大変変わっておりません
コンパクト食べ合わせそうでございます
やはりこういう商品はですねあの強度そのそう品の強度
お客様よくあの落として壊れたという方が多いのでねこういう商品はやっぱり強度な
大雪となっておりますでは咲くすぐ
従来の商品と強度を図っていきましょう
爆こそ従来の商品のコールの街ですねこちらやはり強い衝撃を与えますと
この後な肉酒てしまいますしかしこちらのチーズブーレー
なんと強い衝撃を与えても
ものでございませんこちらの商品不良品の様でございましてねやっぱ生放送というもの
はこういうとこが強いのでございますじゃあさっそくチーズビルで一つの食べてみたい
と思います
これは素晴らしいですね
さりげない5 v もが出ております大変た見やすい商品になっております
何度ですね
只今こちらはジャパネットたかたではん
こちらのチーズブリュレ一つ147が園目
後藤にをいただけますなんと
紹介件で金山からお電話いただいたから30名様限定でこちらの濡れさ何
片方しかないこの靴下ををっ決してなんとお値段変わらず107
文章にゃんだご購入いただけます
すばらしいですねー
ぜひ皆さんこちらの商品欲しい方
こちらので後で打っ
お電話ください
先着三十ですからねこちらの葬儀先着30名の方まであの
プレゼントできますねお値段変わらずですよ
早めのお電話をお待ちしております
ををっ